the Joe Rogan experience I can't wait
till like I'm done with the sport and I
can actually do stuff that'll make me
feel good like you know instead of like
waking up broken every day I'll be like
I can do a little bit of yoga I like to
hike that kind of stuff yeah you're
looking forward to a normal life yes
exactly what what injuries have you had
um I the first the amateur show I was
doing I actually I competed Brian Shaw
who was on the TV show with us
he's four-time world Strongest Man went
out of Colorado he was hosting an
amateur show in Colorado and I'm I was
in Santa Cruz training ocean sea level
went up to outside of Denver to compete
at the show and [ __ ] had a heart
attack it was so so hard but uh it was
the deadlift is it was like maybe two
two months after I started deadlifting
maybe three months so I'd never really
dead lifted and we were dead lifting a
car the back end of a car and they made
it heavy so it was probably for amateurs
heavy is about like eight hundred eight
hundred and forty pounds something like
that so I'm winning the show and and I'm
doing it in front of four-time world
Strongest Man when there who already I
had my sights on him like I was coming
for him you know like I that's like when
I first started I was like okay this
guy's the best this guy's the best I'm
coming for that guy so I wanted I wanted
to show out you know so I go out and I
pull the car up I do the first rap and I
was like just basically it took 90% of
everything I had for that first rep but
like a meathead I was like I'll pull the
second one you know but it's four reps
so I go pull the second one about
halfway up my lower back pops and I just
let go my both my legs went stiff and
then they went numb completely I fall
forward into Brian's arms actually as
he's judging me and my legs were numb
like maybe two months straight and then
off and on for like two years they were
just so bad for that first two months I
actually ended up and I could finish
that show ended up in second place
qualified for Nationals which was my
goal so I could get my pro card
home started training for nationals with
numb legs and had to sleep in my pickup
truck because I wouldn't I couldn't lay
down and we had we had a studio at the
time no chairs we just had to bed and so
I would sleep in my pickup truck get up
drive to the gym go train and looking
back like yeah that was stupid it was
really stupid but that's once I failed
at football in my eyes I'd failed once
once I kind of painted myself in this
corner I was like I'm just I'm just not
gonna lose and you never got an MRI no I
didn't have insurance now you don't want
to get a look-see I kind of do I mean it
feels good now I mean I should take a
peek I'm like I need it I'm gonna go get
my achilles checked out because that
this current list last world Strongest
Man I had a decent pop in my Achilles
and so I'm gonna get that checked out
but I've been been really careful about
how I rehab stuff like that but you're
right yes I should check out my brother
he's crazy though that your legs were
numb for two years yeah off and on there
was straight numb for about two months
straight and I'm like someone could stab
you in the leg like like a sleep oh like
that yeah and it was sciatic it was my
sciatic is what I was told and so you
know I figured that then after that I
was in Africa and I ripped my bicep off
the tendon and I I've been getting
beaten up a lot at that point and like
my first year world Strongest Man it was
so easy for me to get to the finals I
kind of just was like you know [ __ ]
you know it's is whatever I don't have
to work for this I am the strongest man
without having to work for it and then
got in Africa after being beaten up a
lot and kind of getting my head pushed
down in the sand for two years in a row
and ripped that off and I was just like
I'm done
like I in my head like I just thought I
was done I remember walking out by the
river and sitting there and just feeling
like broken just like I didn't know what
I was gonna do with myself or anything
like that
and I walked back to the tent and the
referees were telling me like you know
get your stuff they don't they don't
want you that once you get hurt you have
to fly you home right away
they they don't let you stay and watch
the finish I mean that [ __ ] they
believed yeah
I think it's a liability thing I don't
know basically they just gotta get rid
of you but the judge for the show was
like hey we're doing what's called the
Hercules hold and you're up are you
gonna do it and the Hercules hold means
you reach you reach out with both arms
here like this and you have like a
handle like basically like like in the
gym you know the RO handles like that
attached to a tower that's falling and
you hold it as long as you possibly can
and uh in my mind I was like this is the
last time I'm ever gonna be here so I
might as well leave some [ __ ] blood
on the bar so I've walked out and get it
and it's Oren bicep off the bone
yeah well 10 the tendon so I went over
there I'll just like [ __ ] it like let's
let's at least leave a mark you know
like I had to do something did you tape
it up for anything no what are you gonna
tape up I mean like it's like fully
extended your arm it's basically just
taking weight pulling you and it's so
it's not direct like curling hurting but
it's it's yanking a tendon further in up
into your bicep and I felt that creeping
up into my shoulder as I was doing it
and I did great I actually moves the
best of him I'd had that you know I
crossed it and I remember just closing
my eyes and being gone and just if when
I let go it was almost like being
baptized man like I felt like all the
pain and all the stress everything I'd
felt like build-up once I gotten hurt I
just dumped it all and then it took me
it took me I think it was 2 more years I
finally fought back I thought I was done
and then last year I made it back into
the finals I'm now again top 10
strongest man in the world
so is it was it because of surgery and
Rehab surgery and then everything else
was so beat up once I once I finally
stepped back I was like oh my god
there's no reason I should have to take
an hour to to be able to walk in the
morning yeah and I'm like there's no
reason why my back should hurt from
walking from the front door to the car
you know like I was so racked and so I
just started working on different things
trying to take care of myself and I got
back to Worlds
with that next year actually I got back
and I just didn't do well because I
hadn't been able to do anything and then
came back the following year which was
just this last year and you know I
basically I've been written off it was
it was I was told it was my last time I
was getting invited because at this
point like you're done you know like
it's time for you to find something else
and I came out and I had the show of my
life I've been working so hard but you
never know how strong you are until you
line up you never know like what kind of
athlete you are until you get tested
right so I got I lined up and I'm I got
done I just crushed when I'm when I
finished I loaded that list own and I
knew I was in the finals like dude I did
emotional just think about it right now
like it just felt like somebody just
washed all that away Wow no I remember
ripping my shirt off I am a [ __ ]
showman I'll tell you that I had my
strong and pretty shirt underneath and I
ripped my world Strongest Man shirt and
showed my strong and pretty shirt and I
was just roaring we were in in Malaysia
and like everybody just kind of like
step back a little bit it was awesome so
what kind of stuff do you do to try to
rehab your body to try to get your body
back in the condition ton tons of core
work
tons of stretching and like basically
just digging out scar tissue is huge
it's huge like a lot of people use like
a theron and stuff like that I went the
cheap route I took a Black & Decker
skill saw and I got the stuff
attachments put it all together it cost
me like 65 bucks
[Applause]